hi my name is ron rivest i'm a professor
here at MIT actually an institute
professor and I have a special interest
in election integrity
so my work intellectual integrity
involves ensuring that the outcomes are
what they should be and those involve
either cryptographic techniques or
statistical techniques or sometimes
physical techniques for drawing random
samples of ballots
Computers don't need to play a role in
elections in principle I mean you could
have ballots paper ballots marked my
hand it counted by hand and some
jurisdictions still do that with us so
no computers aren't used at all that's
hard with the United States elections
just because the ballots said to be it's
so complicated and having some computer
assistance and the tabulation seems to
be useful it's not maybe necessary but
it's it's highly useful and so people do
that a lot but then you have to wonder
are those computers doing the right
thing are they giving the right answer
are they tabulating the ballots
correctly and so there's a whole line of
research which I'm involved in which
asks the question how do you competently
arrange it so that that tabulation
process is checkable it's all doable
it's verifiable so that we can see in a
simple manner that we're getting the
right results
the first thing to be concerned about is
voting so voters if they don't vote that
you know they're not participating in
the process second thing is they want to
make sure that their vote is recorded
the way they intend it to be and the
best way to do that is with a paper
ballot we can use machines sometimes to
record votes but there's immense
difficulties with trying to have any
kind of guarantee that the machines are
recording things properly so paper
ballots are the way to go and then you'd
like to see that the collection of the
ballots is done properly and the
tabulation is done properly and that the
outcome was announced correctly and one
of the mindsets that a voter could put
themselves in and say oh I'm a supporter
of this candidate if this candidate
loses what evidence can I look at to
convince myself but the tabulation was
done properly that my candidate actually
lost